I took your side publicly on stream against Kwebbelkop on this
exact topic and he still wouldn't talk to me. So, I feel like
like what am I supposed to do when I sit here and I'm like there's
this malicious lie that's being propagated by someone about me.
What was the lie that my community doxed this people do be boopy.
So, that malicious lie is being spread [music] and you literally
because of guilt by association won't talk to me. Then I mean
unfortunately, I'm playing like the world's tiniest violin for
you when you tell me that you feel like you're getting guilty
by association. Not actually. I actually still because I can't
help it. I'm like the worst kind of odd artist [music] where
I still feel like you don't deserve it. So, I still defend you
even though I think you doing that exact thing to me and I can't
help it. I'll be stuck here forever trying to like defend Hutch
from some tiny mischaracterization on my stream while he just
allows whatever people to say whatever about me, propagates whatever
about me, doesn't give a right?
But apparently
the teeny tiny Tony guy went and talked to Hutch and brought
up like his, you know, his concern about doxxing and stuff. Apparently
he had a good conversation. We'll see how it Okay. Hold on. This
is what Hutch wants to debate on. Tony's back. Tony, come on
buddy. Let's go. Tony wants to call me a Destiny orbiter. Yeah,
somebody want to call him out for calling him a Destiny orbiter
which is bizarre, but all right.
Tony, I was hoping you'd come back. Oh,
Hey, Tony. >> Sorry, I was Sorry, I was uh clipping something
there. How are you How are you doing, Hutch?
Great. I'm so happy to talk to you again. I uh I'm not sure if
you're being sarcastic, but um
I yeah, I was hoping to talk to you. I wanted to
quickly from yesterday, I understand that you thought I was a
troll. I wasn't a troll. >> um Sorry, can you speak up
to us? I'm not trolling right now. Can you speak up a little
bit or get closer to the mic?
Is that any better? I tend to speak quietly. It is better, yeah.
Yeah. I feel like um
I feel like the way that I said a few things yesterday
Uh Tony was the one that came on to Dan, right? Yep. He joins
Letter Box to stream and Hutch's stream. I think.
It's funny they they bring him on. I don't know why they bring
Tony on, but they won't bring like that every time he's bringing
a perspective from like a certain
and they try to ignore other people in that community, but they're
willing to bring Tony on, I guess cuz he's like just a small
Twitter user.
I don't know what do you call that when they're like trying to
find like a
I don't want to say a weaker version cuz Tony's not stupid or
anything, but what do you call that where they like don't want
to interact with the other people be representing those same
ideas directly. It's like it's very weird. Yeah, they're using
him as a proxy. I think there's like
I don't know. It's bizarre.
It's bizarre that you would go, "Oh, well, my interactions with
this community are like too dangerous. I can't do them." which
is Hutch's perspective. And then he's like, "But I'll talk to
this guy. No problem." I think made you upset and that wasn't
my intention. It did upset me. That's true.
But I feel like you and I on Platner specifically don't really
disagree that much. What was the argument about then? Well, the
argument was
Well, let's just I was typing in Well, let's just get to the
core of like what do we agree on?
I don't think that it would be wise
to risk a Senate race against Susan Collins. And even if I don't
like Mills
her politics or her age
to me it seems like the obvious play to take on someone like
Susan Collins. So, like that's the big thing that I think
everything. Do we agree on that? Yeah, we agree on that. Okay,
so he originally comes in to talk about Platner. I don't think
I don't think Hutch wanted to talk about Platner. I think Hutch
wanted to talk about why this guy is calling him a Destiny orbiter.
Hutch uh Hutch like cringes Hutch has a chat command. I don't
know if you guys are aware of this. Hutch has a chat command
Destiny that explains why he's not a Destiny
orbiter.
I don't know why you would ever do that. That seems like the
most bizarre thing to put into practice to me.
You arguing with me. Well, the cuz I I was taking a very specific
like nitpick thing where you were saying
that we knew 100% like 1,000 with absolute certainty that he
lied.
I believe that he lied. I believe it's most likely that he lied
about the tattoo, but I don't think we can say that for certain.
Um that was what I was trying to argue.
All right. I I wonder if you were reading my chat. >> If
you want me to meet you in the middle and say that it's 98% likely
that he lied, then sure. I'll say that. Fine. Sure. Yes. That
was That was That was That was the whole disagreement.
That doesn't You nitpick? You joined the thing just to nitpick
me on that? >> Well, no. I Well, you I wanted to Didn't
Was he not listening? Didn't Tony say this isn't really a big
deal, but like I do have like a tiny nitpick that isn't that
consequential? He like He gave multiple caveats for like this
isn't that big a criticism. I don't think we actually are that
far apart. And then Hutch is like, "You You came out to just
say that. Come on. Say it, man." Oh, you came out just to say
that. Come on. What are you doing, man? >> about the the
Kwebbelkop thing as well. Mhm. You saw that on on Twitter. It
did show up in my mentions, yeah. Yeah. Hold on. Can I pull up
the Let me pull up the tweet.
Uh sure. Cuz I got to say you sound very different on Twitter
than you do when you talk to me.
How do you mean?
Um well, well, for example, if I pull up this tweet here
after coward
That's just everybody. Every Nobody's going to come in and try
to like make you kick them instantly. So, I don't know why streamers
do this. Why would anybody just join your stream and immediately
go, "You loser. You're You're coward. You stupid bitch." Why
would anybody do that? They're just going to expect to get kicked.
Why the are you Why are you acting like this is anything meaningful?
It's so stupid. borrowing from Kwebbelkop
and demanding that he repeat Hutchinson's delusion
that he isn't a Destiny orbiter. Hutch is making up doxxing alle
I Who reads m a n as m o n?
Why would you do that? Why are you You're like intentionally
trying to mispronounce something.
Kwebbelkop
Why are you trying to do it backwards? What the [__]
is this?
allegations against Kwebbelkop's
Some liar, probably not so erudite told him privately, "Does
Hutch forget it was b e who posted his info?" Uh I believe it
was
I believe it was Destiny explicitly who told him that Kwebbelkop
did it, right? Or that it was because of Kwebbelkop.
Like Destiny literally said that he was telling people. He told
Billy Mack and I believe he hinted that he told Hutch. I don't
think it's like on the record fully, but I think it's pretty
clear when you watch the clip. If I remember correctly, I think
when you watch the clip that is what gets said there. Very what?
I would I would say like
Uh I'm on this But then and then you were posting you were repeating
doxxing allegations that are baseless. But then But then you
come into the Discord and you sound
like a little sheepish.
I'm not civil. I'm trying to be friendly and civil.
Why are you trying to be friendly and civil, but you have a totally
different tone in the tweets? Like what's going on there? Cuz
I want to get to the conversation and not
Does Hutch not understand? Has Hutch ever had
I'll just say Watch if Hutch ever talks to Kyle Kulinski again.
Watch the energy shift from like Kyle Kulinski just lies and
tries to equate Republicans and and Democrats to whatever he
does in the conversation. Literally everybody does this. You
start with a neutral tone. You move from there. If you're having
a like a voice conversation, a face-to-face conversation with
somebody. It's just not the same. >> kicked out of the
conversation. Okay, let's get to the conversation.
Oh, wait. Wait. Wait, did No way. Hutch literally kicked Tony
last time because Tony came in with more energy.
So, there's no shot. There's no shot that he kicked that dude.
Cuz I want to get to the conversation and not be kicked out of
the conversation. Okay, let's get to the conversation.
Uh he's so
That's such a thing to do. Uh you you get mad that he's angry
the last time he joins. He has energy and you kick him and then
you and then the next time he shows up he's trying to be polite
so he doesn't get kicked and you go, "Oh, you're like kind of
a [__] aren't you? You're kind of like a [__]
aren't
Good one, Hutch. What What do you want? Yeah.
>> Um a lot of this is going to be about the Kwebbelkop
doxxing allegations. I understand that you said somebody
told you in private
um that his community are crazy and that they are doxxers and
I'm wondering if they gave you any evidence for any of
It was
It was not as things That is a no. Just say no. Don't try to
Don't try to get around it. Say no. I've seen no evidence. specific
to Kwebbelkop's community. It was like the
So, first of all, do you Do you guys call yourselves the commentary
community? There exists like a broad Uh commentary community
and it includes
like a variety of people. Um you know who tried >> Can
I give you some feedback on that?
Uh sure. I think that's a very broad
It is. It's I don't I don't think it's a good label. >> Like
everybody Everybody does commentary. Like it just feels like
>> Yeah, I I agree with you. I don't think the commentary
community is a good word. There's a branding issue there cuz
it's very broad. Cuz I feel like I'm a part of I'm a part I'm
I'm I'm a part of the
This guy is like This guy is like 45 or something and spiritually
like a thousand years old. He is like spiritually somebody who
has never seen
I don't know. He hasn't seen
any telephone. Like in his spirit he is like so he is such a
Luddite. He just can't conceive of
how anybody uses the internet or anything else happens. Like
he can't conceive of the idea of social media these communities
forming. It like you you get a label maybe doesn't even make
How does the alt-right community make sense? How does How does
any label that forms for a community How do How do any of these
labels like make sense?
Sorry, not how but
totally normal for labels to form that don't make sense.
Lots of Lots of counter into Yeah, breadtube. Yeah, there you
go. Breadtube. That doesn't make any sense.
Yeah, kind of but there's also a an overlap between people doing
commentary and people doing or people with a focus on drama will
sometimes also cover politics and you who are mostly focused
on politics will sometimes talk about drama. Mhm. So, there are
there are these overlaps. Okay, I just I just wanted to say I
just feel like there's a branding issue there. I feel like you
need to come up with something >> But it's a it's Maybe
it would be better to do like the drama slot community. I'm not
even saying that as a pejorative.
I'm not even saying like it's beneath It's beneath me to cover
drama slot. Don't know why I don't know Hutcher literally talking
to like a viewer and I think Tony's going to start making videos
or something but he's literally talking to a viewer from one
of those communities. This is like going to This is like going
to Oger Boy and and trying to get him to like change the Hasan
community branding. What are you doing? What Why is this even
a consequential thing you're doing? Like what What are you hoping
to achieve, buddy? Anyways, back to your point. Someone had told
me in a very general
that that space
that Kweiman occupies
there just seems to be a lot of like doxing that occur within
that space.
And did they give you any evidence for that to to be the case?
>> Is that even incorrect? Like is it abnormal for the
subject of the commentary
ire or scrutiny to get doxxed? Is this like a a thing that barely
ever happens or Is there something This is something historically
people have cut other people off for? happens somewhat regularly,
would you say? This feels to me like compare If we compare
this to politics, it feels like saying
we're painting with like extremely broad brushes here. But I
But am I right? Let me like this But Hold on. Can you just answer
that question? It's like is this like a common thing that happens
like No, this is not a common thing. This is a thing that happens
by extremists
in small places who are not allowed explicitly are not allowed
in Kweiman's community, in Jstock's community, in any of these
in Chud's community, in any of these
They do not allow this. So, you're claiming right right here
that that
the subject of commentary for
uh Chud and Kweiman and Jstock Am I saying his name right? With
Jstock people usually say Jstock. Um the subject of their commentary
it's not like normal or common for those people to be doxxed?
No. I mean it wasn't until somebody decided they were just going
to start doxxing everyone. It wasn't. >> What do you mean
the subject of the In fact, I'd say it's way more common
for people close to Destiny to be doxxed regardless of community
they come from.
That's That's just facts. That's the connection Hutch is looking
for. The connection that leads to him and and people around him
being doxxed is not a connection to me at all.
Like let's say there's like a >> Let's say there's like
a like a few weeks where like one particular content creator
comes up a lot
when those three and then other I don't know Are there other
people in the commentary community or are we just talking about
these three people? Like what are we even talking about? >> No,
there there like people like Nicholas DeOrio. You brought on
Willy
You know him? Um he would be considered part of this like part
of these drama
Willy Mac and Nicholas DeOrio would be considered in the in the
same kind of space as like
Just Just Jstock and um Kweiman?
Okay. This is why I say we're painting with very broad brushes
here. It's like saying um
It's like He promoted Willy Mac's dogs. Is this people lying?
Like I I don't know. I feel like you should go when you're on
a stream like this and just tell these people like provide any
evidence. Right? You should be calling them out. I don't know.
I I I assume if I ever got to go on a stream like this, I'd just
say like you can come on and present the evidence you have if
you
Don't be a [__] right? Rogi VO5, don't be a [__]
Come on. Explain. >> Saying does being a liberal content
creator open you up to doxxing
from extremists?
And I think you would agree cuz I know the the history that it
does but that doesn't mean that like everybody who opposes these
ideas
part of this doxxing community or or accepts these tactics like
the guy who did that I will say just to be clear when I look
at all the comments from people
in his chat, it seems like a lot of these people believe things
that Destiny totally makes up, right? Just totally wish cast
into reality.
So, that leads me to believe that the thing that these people
need for certainty in their lives is Destiny's word and no other
facts.
So, when people say why do you think Hutch is a DGG orbiter?
I would say probably cuz there's a lot of DGG talking points
that are totally made up that aren't reality floating around
in your chat that you can't discern at all. Right? You're just
You're totally encapsulated in that ecosystem. You're totally
surrounded by people who say those things. So, you can't even
discern reality. That's why I think probably the best reason
to call Hutch a DGG orbiter would be because his audience is
DGG. that is reviled and shunned as he should
And these like these things
Kweiman, Jstock,
Chud, they're all explicitly against these things. They do not
engage in these things. They do not allow them. They will ban
people from their community
for doing it in other places. Okay. Um I know that there are
um
I know that there is a narrative that's been going around
that Destiny essentially made up
trying to say that there's like a wink wink nudge nudge
with these communities
and their associations with doxxing.
I don't know if you're at all familiar with that but I think
this is this is kind of the the origin point. This is kind of
the origin point about
about where these narratives come from. Oh, look it's Lawson
Oh, Lawson Harrison's there. >> That wasn't the origin.
I I bet you Lawson's got a way to prove this now, right? I bet
you Lawson can totally prove it. Lawson
step it step up join the join the call with Tony and and prove
it out. >> for me. Lawson Harrison, in case you guys don't
know, is the person is Destiny's like number one strongest soldier
who only has Destiny's internal monologue in his head. He's managed
to push all all fiber, all tiny molecule of his own personality
out of his brain so he can have Destiny's entirely. Right? And
he literally believes anything Destiny says. And he he has been
embarrassed multiple times. He's He's said I have all the evidence.
I have evidence of this, right? Been embarrassed multiple times.
Made a complete fool of himself multiple times trying to prove
it out publicly. Hey. Let's see if he goes for it again. Can
I ask who told you? No. Now, can you Did they provide any evidence?
No.
Okay, so
why do you believe them?
I I was skeptical at the time but
what I will tell you is that it was not Destiny that reached
out to me. I have not spoken
>> I don't I I feel like Destiny said
I've not spoken to Destiny directly since I believe
Wait, and I see Can I December Let's not get sidetracked. Let's
not get sidetracked. Let's stay on the Let's stay on the right
track here. Well, don't get don't get stonewalled by Don't get
stonewalled by chat here. Um
Just to be clear I never like specifically
accused
like Kweiman
um like encouraging doxxing.
Okay, so this will be where you go, okay. Well, you didn't do
that but you were going to have a conversation with him. Then
you canceled the conversation.
Okay, you you said it was because of this reason. You propagate
So, basically somebody's lying about you know, Kweiman in this
case. They're lying about Kweiman. You propagate that narrative.
You say, "Oh, I don't know if it's true but I'm not going to
risk it." And you foment like a an environment You create an
environment where people will believe that and they will start
totally like uh what would you call it? They'll totally like
um ostracize these people. Right? Nobody will have conversations
with them because you've taken this thing that's a blatant lie
and you Usually I mean Hutch is starting to engage here but usually
people won't even engage with the fact that it's a lie. Yeah,
anyway. And I didn't even have like No, no, no, no, Portobello.
He explicitly makes He makes it clear that there's another person
he's messaged about it, okay? a strong opinion about
where it came from. I can't >> The se I don't have the
clips. I don't have the clips anymore. I'll try to figure it
out at some point but I'm almost positive he says there's like
another place that it came from. >> of events was I really
hope Tony says, "You understand that the the doxxing of you that
that you've had attributed to Kman was done on you without you
being informed apparently
months before that in September of 2024 before any of the Destiny
leaks happened. of events was like somebody had reached out to
me and said, "Be careful wading into those waters
Because a lot of people that interact
those creators end up getting doxxed. And I was like, "Okay,
well I mean I
It seems fine. This guy doesn't seem like too crazy."
I didn't really know much about Kman at that point. I had watched
like one video. And then it was like
the next day or like two days later that an old doc started to
get spread.
Now I understand that
Uh he said he has a source he won't expand on like less than
a minute ago. Oh, I I understand that Evil Johnny Bravo. He said
he has a source, right? And then he said it's not Destiny. I'm
telling you that I I believe and again I don't have proof of
this so it's not like a full thing, but I remember Destiny saying
he'd sent it to somebody else or talked to somebody else. That
was my impression. I I maybe I maybe like laying it on a little
too thick. I have like this impression.
I don't think anybody should like take action on that impression
obviously. >> that Bad Empanada had been doing videos
at that point where he had been calling attention to the doxx.
And that kind of like made it I could just be willing to match
her. >> fresh. And I can't I can't remember like the timeline
but I think the potential conversation with Kman was like some
time after the BE stuff.
And even when the even when BE started doing it
like I did I didn't start seeing it like trickle into my like
stuff.
So it seemed like even though he was covering it was it was it
seemed like somewhat limited there. But then but then it was
just like
like a couple days before I was supposed to have a conversation
with Kman that people started spreading it like crazy.
And at that point I didn't really care like where it came from.
It just it just felt like I don't like where this situation's
going like that
community seemed seemed like very toxic now that I
I've spent a little bit more time looking at their Twitter feeds
and maybe watching some of their videos. And so I just decided
I don't want to have this conversation it's just not worth it.
And then I privately asked Kman I was
It seems to be that you know the case that a lot of people in
your community are under the impression that I'm a Destiny orbiter.
>> Yeah. like
I I didn't again, I don't know anything about Kman at this point
so I think I'm having a conversation with just like
an like a grown-up.
Cuz I've had these kind of conversations in private with other
creators even other creators that didn't like me and I didn't
like them.
And and I have been amicable amicable bull to people in that
spot and they've been amicable bull to me. I can't speak right
now. Holy [__] And you know those conversations were
you like normally they go fine.
But I said this to him and he got and he says something like
"Well, I'm just not going to I'm just not going to lie to my
audience."
And I was like I remember that. >> Well, hold on. I'm not
done. And I was like
Hold on.
I'll keep watching but he
I don't understand where where does he arrogance come from? Like
no no no, you should you should say the opposite of your opinion
to make me feel better. I don't know why I don't know why somebody
can have the arrogance to have that
And then I don't remember how it played out but I asked him I
was like "Why do you why would you call me a Destiny orbiter?"
And he said because I make Destiny
Can you explain can you What what is what does that mean?
Well, do you agree that Hassan has an orbit that he almost never
talks to?
Well, well dude he looks so confused. What what just happened
to his brain? >> How would you define Well, do you agree
that Hassan has an orbit that he almost never talks to? Well
Like what what happened? What happened?
How would you define Hassan's orbit? What does that mean to you?
Well, Hassan would you
Um orbit is going to be kind of a nebulous word but would you
agree that people like Mike from PA
um Denims, Frogan are in Hassan's orbit? I mean Denims for sure
because she actually like got the invite for that content nuke
thing or whatever. Mike is They they don't have to interact with
the person. I I'm asking you this.
I know that you have talked about these people as explicitly
as >> would say Mike >> You've talked about Gato
Fumador as a Hassan orbiter.
Gato Fumador has never appeared
on video. But he they have an explicitly friendly relationship.
Hassan has boosted
got I don't I don't think by the way I like I don't even think
this is I think you can give this up and not have any problems
and still just go no it's not the same. >> Gato Fumador
Like why I don't know why
Gato. Yeah, I don't know why they're saying Gato. I don't know
why he thinks he can't give this up and be fine. uh stuff. They
have like a relationship with each other.
Even if it's not like even if it's not like a super close relationship
it's like a friendly relationship that they
Um I cherry the differences between Hutch and Abba is that Abba
has a career outside of Destiny. Yes, outside of like even the
space the politics space. I think Hutch was a politics neophyte
in a lot of ways. He was not doing as well with his channel and
a lot of support from like Destiny or Destiny adjacent communities
is what sort of propped him up and got him going as like a politics
commentator. That's how I view it. That's how I think other people
would view it whereas Abba's never had any sort of support like
that. I don't I don't know if I care about Hutch calling Hutch
an orbiter orbiter particularly. I think that's a big difference
between Abba and and Hutch that like I think Hutch built a career
as a streamer in a totally different field like entirely different
field and then he came over to politics. Also this is my thing
is I think if his community is broadly going to repeat like Destiny
creative writing as fact then I I'm going to consider that a
Destiny orbiter, right?
I that's just that's fine with me.
Again, I think Abba passes that test as well. uh Mike and Hassan
have had a friendly relationship for a really long time. Mike
has been desperately trying
to get into Hassan's orbit showing up in his chat and trying
to do this and like calling himself the waiting room. It's like
very obvious he is deliberately
Yeah, this is again I understand um I understand this is like
a narrativizing thing. I get it a little bit but this is not
true. Like obviously Mike is a Hassan orbiter. Obviously they
talk they have private DMs and stuff. I think it's kind of insane
to suggest
that like Mike's just I understand you want to evoke those optics
that Mike is like you know he's like the sad cat sitting outside
the window like wiping away the fog and looking inside and wishing
he could come inside. I get the optics he's trying to evoke here.
I just don't agree. Like if you're a Kman you want to be petty
that's the only reason you call someone an orbiter when they
don't want to be called that. Um I think
So I see it as different Cherry but I understand how that's I
understand that's how it seems to people. I think for Kman the
way he sees it and I explained this at the time it was um basically
he believes that Hutch would like immediately start doing content
with Destiny again the second the Pixie lawsuit is either dismissed
or if Pixie loses. If Pixie wins probably not but Hutch is like
literally right around the corner from doing uh content with
Destiny again from politics perspective. I think that's his opinion
and he says I think he believes it would be wrong of him to not
say that explicitly if he's
And that basically if he if he said no no no he's not an orbiter
he feels like his reputation would be hurt if it came out that
if if those events came to
Pretty sure I've seen Kman say he would debate Destiny. How can
he grandstand on
Um again Destiny adjacent community Destiny adjacent content
creators Kman sees himself as adversarial. Like he's done a lot
of content against Destiny. I don't agree that I don't necessarily
agree that Hutch is an orbiter by the way. I think the best argument
is the chat just taking things that Destiny has lied about and
presenting it as fact. I think that's an easy argument. I think
Hutch loses to Kman and basically anybody else here. Like hey
I I like started talking about this and your chat started relaying
lies. Um that to me proves it automatically. Like you were just
relaying lies and you can't prove this and I know you can't prove
this. Right? And I know it doesn't concern you cuz it's about
other people you don't care about. So you're willing to have
total blatant lies from another content creator pervade your
community. It doesn't bother you cuz you don't and and you don't
want to dispel it. You don't care to dispel it or take any effort
to dispel it because obviously if you if you said that that wasn't
true those people might go away.
That's why you don't want to dispel it. So Hutch's lack of concern
and willingness to just take what he can get from Destiny's community
and and not be concerned about how that affects anyone else I
say that that's concerning in and of itself.
yeah, that's just me. Yeah, maybe.
I think I think I have my reasons that I believe both sides are
like reasonable in their asks here. I think Hutch just doesn't
care to understand what Kman's side of that would be. Which I
mean is his prerogative but I think just then don't propagate
the lies just keep them inside and don't propagate them outwards,
right? But now Hutch has propagated them outwards and I think
he's responsible for that.
So while I I would have probably agree I lean away from calling
him an orbiter. I think he is totally responsible for allowing
this lie to spread. Like trying to be closer to Hassan and like
benefit from that
Like you you would you would agree that that is a very different
dynamic
than like me with Destiny. Surely you would agree, right? >> No,
I wouldn't agree.
How do you explain that?
Uh do you want me to lay it out?
Yeah, that's why I asked you.
Okay, so a lot of this comes from
you responding to Ogre Boy at one point where you said
that you are not that you should not be considered a Destiny
orbiter in part because you
don't talk to him directly, but you and we just spoke you agreed
Gato Fumador or Gato Fuma whatever
Gato Fumador is an orbiter even though they don't I have Wait,
sorry. I don't mean to be rude.
Yeah. I This guy is an anti-fan.
How do Bro, these people are just total sheep. It's bizarre.
Give me just a minute.
Bro, that sounded alarming. That sounded very alarming. Tony
Why is Tony Tony needs to start monologuing right now. Why is
he not monologuing the whole time? Brain broken erudite A-log.
Don't talk to me, creep. Oh, sorry.
Sorry, Devin.
I'm not going to use slurs, don't worry.
Like you you should just be talking like literally any of you
saying that these communities are like doxing communities, you
cannot prove this out at all. You literally can't prove it. You
have no evidence. Sorry, you have no evidence that they don't
take steps. So, I'm sure there could be cases where like somebody
has done
like uh what would you say? That somebody's done like some malicious
doxing thing, right? You you can't show that there's like no
steps taken to curb that behavior, to moderate out that
You just can't show it. Although I will say there are people
I've unbanned from my Discord. Uh I can't I can't explain
Yeah, who like might have done some stuff that could be perceived
as like going after me.
I have forgiven that cuz I have I can make that decision, okay?
That's all.
Ego. Hello, Mad Naughty with the five gifted. Thank you very
much, man. Appreciate it, buddy. This is a thing that was shown.
Actually, maybe I should just wait for
The best part about this is I like I should actually the it's
so [__] that they won't talk to me cuz I understand
that most of the people who are like active, I know a lot of
people from my community.
Yeah, Tony's doing good. No, Tony's doing very good right now.
I want to see things happen the way I want them to happen. Can
I get unbanned, too? Didn't even dox you. Yeah, you probably
just needed to stop joking about murdering one of the moderators,
Azel. I don't know what to tell you.
I don't I don't like I don't even want you banned, but I told
you if you can't stop joking about murdering people who run the
server, you're probably not going to be here. You couldn't stop
like at any point, so it's like not even a high bar. It's like
a such a low bar.
I got banned for porn posting. Okay. All right. Yeah, Tony's
doing good. Oh, Hutch is back. We got Hutch back. >> embarrass
me, did you, Tony? No, I I didn't really say anything. >> I
figured you wouldn't Oh, I was going to say it sucks that I can't
be in these conversations cuz like people will try to use
people will try to use that one Queenman thing against him. I
guess with me they could use like the Oda Charlotte letter.
>> If you want to do that, I I suppose. >> me to
talk too much.
Okay, so the question was just to refresh, what is But like But
like I don't have something like the what do you call it? The
the Baden Penautic clip where Queenman's clearly not Sorry, I
shouldn't call it the Baden Penautic clip. I should call it the
Destiny tweet, right? Queenman has the Destiny tweet on his screen.
he doesn't see it. It plays some of Willy Mac's doxing info,
which Destiny didn't apologize for. Destiny didn't say it was
wrong. He said, "Oh yeah, sorry Willy, I might have blown you
up, but everybody else I don't care." Queenman was like, "Oh,
I'll edit that out of everything." Destiny was like, "Oh, Destiny
unretweeted it." But then said he didn't care, so I don't know.
Somewhere in the middle with both of >> Destiny adjacent
content. What does that
Well, the the question is do you agree
or the question is are you an orbiter essentially? Um That's
your question. I wanted you to ask what is Destiny adjacent content?
We could call Destiny adjacent content content that appeals specifically
to his audience. So, we could say that What does it mean to >> We
might say What does it mean to
What does it mean to appeal specifically
to Destiny's audience? That's Well, we know that a difficult
thing for me to wrap my mind around cuz if me and Destiny have
very similar politics, which um Oh man, I gave my answer like
instantly. I hope Tony has something
>> Then there's obviously going to be a lot of overlap,
but I'm not targeting any audience. I also want to ask like how
much do you know about me as a creator? Like how much of my history
do you know? Um I'm I'm familiar with I know you used to be a
Call of Duty guy. I know you talked about how um you got into
Call of Duty after the
the Gore Bush election.
Mhm. And you were always very interested in politics. You were
um
you started politically streaming more
a while ago. I forget exactly. You had You talked with Destiny
not super frequently on stream, but occasionally.
I know that politically you are You you know that you know the
deep lore. You've done a deep dive on me. What? What if he's
just been watching these communities for a long time? I I've
known who you are for a while. And so you know you know that
I've had like my own career that goes back to 2009,
Yeah, I'm aware of that.
Okay, I just wanted to be sure we were on the same page about
Yeah. Um
But you're talking you asked me
how does um
You said it doesn't make sense like the notion of appealing to
a Destiny audience. You were talking just now
Mike from PA. Yeah. Yeah, you're talking about Mike from PA appealing
to Hassan's
Is he sort of how do you how do you identify that Mike from PA
is appealing to Hassan's audience?
Oh, I think Tony could maybe logically win this. I think a more
Tony specific path would be something like
uh look at how much he's look at how much time you spent on Colorgate.
You have somebody in your movement who's done something far worse
than Colorgate who you just let skate and you don't bring up
their [__] ever. So, that seems kind of [__]
up to me that you would spend so much time on Colorgate as drama
and you write off this other thing that's clearly like really
really really bad. You don't really get informed on it. You don't
look into it very much. You just sort of push it to the side.
That lack of concern is what I think is positive coverage. I
think that's you helping somebody out. I I think you could if
you were Tony you'd make that argument. I I don't really like
that argument as much, but I I do think Tony might get
>> and publicly
tries to
>> associate himself
with Hassan, be seen as Hassan's friend.
Would you agree with that?
Uh yes, I think so.
There you go. But he also would you agree that he also aligns
his content
with Hassan? He frequently covers Hassan content or the stuff
that Hassan
and like he covers the same types of things that Hassan would
cover on his stream in the same
or in a way that would appeal
probably that he knows would appeal
to that same audience. I would I would suspect so, yeah. I would
suspect that he wants to be he wants to be a waiting room. Right?
Yeah, but he >> He's like an alternative for Hassan viewers
when Hassan isn't online. Yeah, but he has uh directly
and publicly
made and continues to make great efforts
to like be a part of Hassan's community. I think I think I think
I understand
I don't think that needs to happen. I I just don't think so.
I think a lot of the people that you would be you would consider
like Hassan orbiters like the sort of progressives on Twitch
ball who give him like a lot of positive coverage sort of sweep
for him. I think you consider those people like Hassan >> Where
you're going with this? You you explicitly know that there's
a bigger audience over top of you that flows down into you and
you do not want to upset that audience by saying offensive things
about the content creator they worship.
Right? Would be the the broad argument you'd be going for as
Tony. >> So, go ahead and just make the point. Well, I
Yeah, I'm saying essentially that you do this with Destiny. I
can lay out examples.
I would say if you distort reality on their behalf, if you distort
reality on their behalf, that's probably
Right? Is that I feel like that's fairly generalized and also
works pretty well.
But I I
It seems to me that you have Wait, hold on. You you can lay out
examples of me
trying to >> my reasoning. >> be a part of Destiny's
orbit like his community like me trying to have an association
with
Like a like an actual like direct relationship with Destiny?
Um well,
there's a bit of that with
Do you remember your the Destiny situation video that you uploaded
to
Yeah, remember that. That was
I don't I personally see Hutch's watch walk back here as like
not that consequential if I remember it It was basically saying
I wish I just hadn't commented at all. Um I think
I think I sort of I went through that and I remember being like
okay, this isn't quite as bad as it seems. Like I understand
what he what he wanted to walk back was the idea that he was
like taking away his forgiveness from this person because of
his time in like uh narc narcotics anonymous. No, NA NA, right?
Is what he's in? It's not AA, it's NA, right?
I think I think I'm trying to think of like what whatever addiction
program he said. He wanted to
he wanted to basically not say that I can't possibly forgive
this person. Now that wasn't to suggest there was like an easy
past or path to redemption,
but I do think that he pretty explicitly
like it doesn't make it okay. I'm not like happy about it. I
just feel like I you know, I should commit to this thing where
people are forgivable. They are
Yeah, which is fine to me. As long as and he did it he did the
thing, right? You have to point out that they've made no walk
they haven't taken a step down that path yet. Like they aren't
working towards it even. So I I can't entertain being around
them, collabing with them while they're not entertaining like
redemption or not attempting to redeem themselves in any way.
I do so I remember that video going up. I don't remember the
That was you responding to some clips that were going around
of people talking about you um uh characterizing it something
like you egging for a position
Yep, I remember that as well Porter Beller. I do remember that
that he said some things were revealed to him that made it things
sound different. I do remember that. I do think it's inappropriate
for him to talk about that in public.
I think he shouldn't have said that, For sure. But that's like
a mistake.
talking to like you were open to rebuilding the bridge with Destiny
is what people were saying about that. >> I remember the
commentary
from um reacting to something that I had said to food shops.
Yeah, there was the food shops clip and there was another previous
clip. Mhm.
part of these were examples of building a personal relationship
with Destiny and I can lay out my reasoning for why. I understand
that you've responded. I've looked through your response.
I think your response is misleading. I see that you're I know
there's a bit of a delay on stream, but I see you making
I thought that I had made myself like very clear >> this
is a stupid comment. I mean I I think you'd have to be really
really if you think Hutch should talk to Meerklyman at all and
you criticize him for talking to food shops, I think you sound
really to be honest with you. And I think if I was I feel like
you would be vindicated
if at some point from the time of all that discourse until now
I started to
like actively
try to establish
a working relationship with Destiny.
Which that is just obviously not
Why do you select her over Queeman? I'm you're you're trying
to fight me Ryl. I just think that Okay. Uh why did he because
she was somebody who's putting like Hutch defense squad in her
title? He said explicitly, do you not remember that? How many
times has Queeman had Hutch defense squad in his title?
That's like the original reason that he talked to her in the
first place.
No, that hasn't happened. The reason that hasn't happened Oh,
well that is exactly why he talked to her in the
>> He said so when he joined.
he was caught retaining um
material that was illegal.
You're claiming that I would have reached out and tried to collaborate
with him again had it not been for
the Rose stuff? Is that what you're talking about?
Yes, that's my belief. Okay.
Yeah, that's I think that's >> to explain what I don't
know for sure, but I believe Queeman thinks something somewhat
similar and he believes that like because of that like desire
to start collaborating again
I I think
that's why they think he's a Destiny orbiter. That's why they
say it. They feel like if they say oh, he's not a Destiny orbiter
implying like he doesn't want anything to do with Destiny and
then you know, the Pixie case gets dismissed or settled and he
immediately collabs with Destiny again, then they look stupid
and well, Queeman looks stupid in front of his audience, right?
Like it looks like he's And and you can you can like say things
are different. You could like for a friend maybe say oh, this
is like not true and like trust them, but why is he going to
sacrifice his own opinion, make himself risk making himself look
worse in this case for somebody he doesn't really know. It just
doesn't make any >> Well, I think you're
the reasoning you gave in your response to these clips
wasn't very good. This is all a bit silly, don't you think?
No. I Okay, I'm good I just kind of lay it out.
I understand that you don't like the This what? I I Can he engage
with anything? Why do you just not engage and go this is really
That's really silly, isn't it? That's not a response.
That's not even remotely a response.
What the [__] are you doing? Uh it just reminds me
of how like there's so many people who don't have actual conversation
like I don't know. I don't know. I don't want to be like a
I don't understand how
I'm I'm just going to I'm going to hold my tongue. You know,
you know the the old saying the old wisdom, if you don't have
anything nice to say, don't say anything at all. Oh, Cherry,
this was about Queeman as well, right? That it's tit for tat.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I don't think it's I don't think it's that.
I I really don't. But unfortunately, it's always going to seem
that way. That's like the exact impression that um Queeman gives
off for better or worse.
I do I do understand why
Hutch is mad about this topic and it's one Hutch brought up.
Well, I think Tony was saying in the chat Ryl. Wasn't he saying
something about him being a an
to label orbiter um I have You talked a bunch of times in the
video about how >> not say it? We want your commentary.
Uh no, it was just me being like
snarky not in the H3 snark way, just
yeah, you don't like that specific label. You've been doing your
own content for 15 years. You're
I see a lot of the same names in your chat that are
DGGers. I know that you
um have a This is This is using a label instead of an action
makes it much harder or much easier for him to defend this, okay?
If you just say I see DGGers, I see name overlap. That's easily
a label. Those people could just they could say whatever they
want. What you should be saying is I saw a bunch of these people
say that these guys are from doxing that this guy Tony's from
a doxing community. They all dox. Look, here's here's like this.
I can explain how they dox, right? But none of them will come
in here and try to explain it. For one thing, none of them have
any proof of this. They just totally wish cast, right? It's just
it's just I'm going to try to make my mentalization become reality.
They're they're employing the secret, okay? They're trying to
visualize they're trying to what is it? Not materialize. What's
the word? What's the word? It's Cherry, I'm looking at you. The
secret. What am I trying to do when I use my Manifest. Yes, they're
manifesting. They're all manifesting.
Thank you.
It's there's no way that the first person to say it in chat.
Okay, Cherry said it first, but then in chat it was straight
away. That's crazy. That you just came That's That's crazy. That's
just a crazy coincidence right there, isn't it? Jesus. Yes.
And and I think that to me like if they all have this shared
delusion that comes from a specific
place that I'm going to
they're like it's a delusion. I'm going to assume they're loyal
to that place if they have that delusion. That I think that's
a totally fair assumption to make, right? If people think that
um if people believe in theetons, I'm going to assume that they're
Scientologists.
That's how it goes, man. I don't know what to tell you. You got
beliefs that are totally made up. I'm going to assume you have
the label that's commensurate with those
So theetons theetons, they're a thing from Scientology, Krieger.
I think in this chat I've seen multiple times people say all
of the doxing stuff that Destiny's laid out with no
I would just point that out to Hutch and say that's allowed to
manifest in your chat. It's allowed to be there in your chat.
You don't bother looking it up cuz it doesn't bother you and
there's one of two reasons. Either you don't care that people
are making this up and and hurting these other people, which
is bad, or you won't clear it up because you know that it's going
to make those people who give you money, who show up and give
you money specifically because you don't badmouth Destiny. It's
going to make those people leave. Those are really the only two
options. The third option is that you're ignorant, but you've
shown you're not ignorant because you've actually engaged in
this conversation and said you're not going to have collabs with
these people. You blocked me on Twitter before actually engaging
with me in any way at all. It's theeton. I don't think it's theeton.
Well, it's theetons in South Park, so that's what I'm going to
call him. >> audience with him. Significant common audience
with him. So you know that um I don't know about significant,
but like you know that um Pretty significant. So what? That I've
I've had like Again, you have to It sucks because
when you know you're right, when you have like all the pieces
in your head to say you're right, I understand that you still
have to be able to prove it. Uh Lost in Harrison says inshallah
to that, by the way. Inshallah, he says.
He's like yeah, I am I am totally mind Yes. Yes, proudly.
Yeah, you just man
You have to He knows he's right. It's easy to get emotional and
just label them. You have to describe it like calmly, specifically
in a way that can't be refuted, right? Cuz I'm just giving you
guys like facts of reality right now. I'm not I'm not relying
on rhetoric or persuasion. I'm just telling you this is like
Many people in your chat are saying something that is
unverifiable. It's It's literally unknowable and they're saying
it as if it's fact. That belief comes from a certain place. I'm
going to associate that behavior of having that totally
un- or what would you call it? Unprovable, unverified belief.
I'm going to call their their belief in that out for what it
is. It's It's coming from a community. It's coming from somewhere
with a specific Somebody's specifically driving that. That's
pretty simple. Like conflict with
Yes, I know that you >> last I should I should write this
down so I can actually like make a clip out of this, but it's
I think it's pretty obvious. >> a couple months, right?
Yes, I remember that when um you were disagreeing with Destiny
over
um You really know the >> disavowing violence thing. Yeah,
I've been um you know >> your stream every day. It's the
what >> What do you mean deep lore? He watches your stream
every day.
Every day. And it's the the it wasn't the it it was the rhetoric
>> the disavowing like
And it was about more recently about um
kind of the general kind of gist of it was like
people people seem to be expressing a desire that the Democratic
Party
um be kind of like match the unhinged
nature of MAGA.
And uh this is you know, and it it goes beyond that though cuz
then it turns into a conversation about
it's kind of crazy when a creator is
This Isn't this from like a long time ago? The Oh although no,
it was actually recent as well.
the the pact most DGGers have made with like every other content
creator is just don't badmouth Destiny and we're fine, right?
Just talk about the politics. Don't badmouth Destiny. We're fine.
The overlap is detectable in other ways. A lot of the people
in their audience take it to extremes.
Or or not even that. If a creator is like disagreed with even
lightly,
then there appears this sort of parasocial kind of instincts
to interpret that as an
Uh how many Jesus, Total Jenny Death.
How many viewers does this guy get? What percentage are DGGers?
I This is unknowable, right? It's just I can I'm looking at the
chat, the people who are
right? I'm looking at the people who are engaged who are repeating
these things. That's all. I can't say 100% of his community.
I can't say 50% of his community. I can't say 10%. I don't know
the number, right? I'm saying the people who are engaged, I'm
watching the messages they're sending.
They are coming off a certain way. And that's been like a
like a recurring thing that has occurred
uh like multiple times and I've spoken to that. Like multiple
times.
If I was someone that was trying to ingratiate myself with someone
like Destiny, I just don't understand how I would be picking
that kind of fight with those people in my chat.
It just doesn't >> goes on a bridge too [clears throat]
far and you disagree with him,
I would expect like any human being to disagree with his take
on disavowing political violence, on refusing to disavow political
violence until Trump does. I think that would be a bridge too
far for anybody.
But I also recall
and this is part This is why I bring this up is cuz you have
common audience with him, significant common audience with Because
when that happened, we saw that there was massive backlash and
tons of people piling into your waiting room. A huge number of
people disagreeing. The vast majority of your chat How many people
How many people do you think in that Discord
would like were in those channels at that time?
It's like a dozen people? Maybe like 16
How many people do you get like for most of your call-ins? I
would say more than like two people I'm guessing is a big
It's more like 20.
This is what you're saying is like an overwhelming
Bro, like 20 people were in his waiting room waiting to talk
to him?
Dude, that's insane.
This is one of the Bro, I can't remember the last time I I watched
Destiny. I can't remember the last time Destiny had 20 call-ins
for his show for people disagreeing. Okay, maybe I can. It's
like summer 2023 or something. But still, that's a long time
ago when he did call-ins a lot. >> of people This is one
of the indicators. This is one of the indicators. Another indicator
How do you Well, hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. >> It's your
chat which you said at the time was turning on you. You said
this at the time. >> Hold on. Okay, well, now Tony Now
Tony has me beaten, okay? Tony has some points that I didn't
even think of cuz I don't watch Hutch. All right? But Tony's
using Hutch's own words to beat him to death. Stop hitting yourself,
Hutch. Stop hitting yourself with your own words, buddy. I don't
know how familiar you are when there's like controversy whenever
a creator is like covering a topic.
>> Evil Jenny But sometimes especially when it involves
another creator,
you'll get an influx of people
who will be watching your content specifically because you're
discussing that creator.
That doesn't mean that you have like this overwhelming overlap.
These were regulars in your audience and your viewership numbers
were more or less the same.
Even if Hold on. Even if that was the case, like what issue do
you have in particular with that?
It's part of building up It's part of
that you were
or that you can can can be considered a Destiny orbiter.
Is the shared audience. What's the issue with that?
I don't think he was arguing 20 people of crossover. It's uh
It's just like so lazy. These people are so lazy.
But it's pretty hard to go into somebody else's stream like this
and >> of the same audience. You appeal to the same people.
You say a lot of the same things. You have the same obsession
with
Your Your >> Yeah, bring up Bring up Hasan. Saying the
word Hasan in this is going to break everyone's brain in that
chat. Tony's not trying to like do He's I think he's pretty clearly
just trying to say his
No thought to like making this audience understand or or anything
like that, which is fine. Your categories of overlap are insanely
broad. Like if I have an overlap with >> same audience?
The same viewers? >> have an overlap of opinions with someone
>> You have the same or you surround yourself with people
who >> I I can't do this.
I can't do this. Don't have the patience for this. Um
This is like so insanely
broad.
I do believe he goes back once here. Like if I have similar opinions
on
or a particular cre-
Then Lunar Box is still an orbiter? Yeah, I think uh I think
Tony would almost certainly consider Lunar Box still an orbiter.
I think if you hang out with Dan, it's pretty hard to I It sucks
that
it it sucks that um cuz I don't think Lunar Box is an orbiter.
I I know like what I a solid feeling of what Lunar Box's personal
feelings are,
but there's just some other stuff going on there that I don't
know. I I just don't see orbiter fitting in the same
Creator. These are insanely
broad
Should I specifically avoid having particular opinions about
things
for fear that I might overlap with a creator over here? Like
how am I supposed to avoid the label? What can I possibly do?
Uh I just I'm I'm literally going to lay it out that it's a totally
made up a Like basically
you let something go through your chat that is harmful to other
people. Yeah, it's It's just going to be like I I basically I'm
just like, "Oh,
you're allowing harm to befall people who like haven't earned
it in any way? That seems like a bad thing." But honestly, I'm
asking that of like internet creators. Internet creators have
no reason to actually do that. It's not like a logical argument,
right?
whatever. If they just don't care to um if they don't care to
engage in that way, that's totally fine. I mean, it's I It's
totally fine. It's not really totally fine. It's sort of like
really [__] up, but it's one of those things where
it's like, "What can you do?"
People are racist. What can you do? Haha. To avoid that label.
>> not going to change it anytime soon, so I might as well
move on. All right. Give me just a minute. Be right Oh, Total
Jenny Death, do you even know what my argument is? When did you
get here? Cuz I laid out my argument pretty quickly, right? If
you believe that Queen Man Chud me that our community is doxx
people or broadly known for doxxing people, have broadly doxxed
people, allow doxxing of people, if you have any beliefs like
that, right?
Then you should be able to point them out or or sorry, you should
be able to post evidence for them. There's essentially no evidence,
no solid link whatsoever.
There's like a clip of There's a chatter in Chud's Discord who
got banned immediately after posting um like a picture of like
a fake picture of WillyMac's wife that wasn't even real, I
And then there is but but he thought it was a doxx, so it's like
you get that guy out, right? And then there's Queen Man looking
at the Destiny tweet and not realizing that WillyMac's doxx flies
by in the Destiny tweet, right? Those are the two instances
that are like known.
And I don't think that proves anything because Queen Man did
everything he could to fix it after it happened. It was a total
accident. And Chud did everything he could at to fix it afterwards,
but or his mods did. I don't even think he had to actually do
something. And that that's used as like proof that these are
doxxing communities. So, Total Jenny Death, just listen again.
If you have a totally delusional belief that cannot be sourced
in any way from reality and the propagator of that belief is
a specific group, right? So, you believe in Patons like the sci-
the Scientology thing that causes toxicity in your life, Thetans,
right? If you believe in Thetans
or your chat believes in Thetans and you don't say anything about
it, you just let that that belief propagate, then I think your
chat are mostly from the cult that made that thing up. And so
that's why when I see the topic come up and everybody in the
chat is repeating the same lie, I'm like, "Oh, they're a part
of the same cult." That that would be my argument. I think it's
pretty easy. I'm
And by the way, I would say for to prove that like somebody is
a dox- to prove a community doxes, you'd probably need significantly
more of that happening with less moderation than other communities.
And I'd say by any measure
Chud's community, my community, Queenman's community probably
beats DG Giddo by like a mile, right?
Like I again, I never say like no doxing happens, but it's against
the rules, those people are banned when the rules are violated.
And then we're going to continue with the uh so this poll came
The uh And um Oh, sorry, sorry. He copes for 10 minutes. And
all the grand platner ride or die people were like so they were
like posting the poll and being like, "Boom, suck it." And they
asked the
it it brings out like this intense
and it is something that I've never been comfortable with. Like
Uh I said this as well earlier, Sci-Fi, that Hutch is like political
stream, like his transition into political streaming, was tended
to by some people who were either Destiny or Destiny adjacent,
right? I don't I don't personally hold that like against him.
I'm I'm fine with that with like that happening. I don't think
he has to be called an orbiter. Um I don't think it's like super
consequential to call him an orbiter, so I just wouldn't do it
cuz he doesn't like it. I just I also understand the people who
would call him an orbiter. I understand their points.
Yeah. Like I very specifically and deliberately tried to
cultivate an audience of people that are not doing like parasocial
parasocial like stuff to me. Hutch, don't take these people seriously.
They're on a personal crusade to destroy Destiny and if you're
not 100% on their side and constantly fighting to achieve it,
you're guilty.
Um see this is like verifiably if if Hutch just ever watched
me talk about this, I think this is just like verifiably untrue,
but unfortunately there are people who are willing to spend like
hundreds of dollars to propagate this message
uh which which blows kind of pretty
Like what do you do? I literally This must be how like some politicians
feel. They they say something that gets like clip-chimp at some
point and then they just have that narrative about them their
entire career and they're just like, "Oh, I guess people are
going to spend like tons of
relatively to spread a narrative about me that isn't true." That's
that kind of That must be to them. And part of that like comes
from
experience because I had a situation
Uh total Jenny Death, why don't you hop in the Discord? discord.gg/jsto
k. We can just talk there. It seems like you have some stuff
and I just rather talk through it if you if you actually disagree
with anything I'm saying, I'd rather just talk through
It'd just be faster.
I don't even know if you're disagreeing with me here. Let me
pull it up. I mean it does seem like a lot of you guys go after
Hutch a lot. Like if Hutch just said he didn't think you or or
have any proof you guys are a doxing community, but he just didn't
want to deal with Queenman, is there some issue outside of that?
Well, I'm blocked by him. I've asked him for conversations and
he basically treats me the same way. So it's not even the just
Queenman, oh he's a total douchebag thing. I've asked him for
conversations
and I've been denied on I assume the same grounds or just guilt
by
which I think is unfair, personally.
Uh as far as I know, I'm still blocked on Twitter
despite basically never tweeting at Hutch. I I guarantee you
I had like some disagreement, some like negative comment towards
Hutch, but I don't think it's ever been crazy. And like he doesn't
have he's not required to unblock me, but let me see here. Yeah,
we're still blocked. Still blocked.
So like I
I don't know where to go from there, right? Or just like
there was like a big blow-up. I've talked about this like a thousand
times, but there was like a big blow-up within within my community
of people that were like intensely react And like I would say
to Hutch, like the person, whoever your secret source is, is
like maliciously trying to harm me financially
and you're willing to like let that sit there, which I I think
is pretty [__] up. Like it should you have to understand
that that to me
when I when I go to you and I say, "Hey, this is like totally
wrong. These are like lies, like open obvious lies." Oh, well
I can't go to him actually, so he's blocked me from being able
to speak to him. Yeah, see total total Jenny Death, I know you
won't hop on, so I just feel like you understand that you're
basically saying you disagree because you don't know stuff and
then I lay out my position, you don't lay out a disagreement,
you lay out a feeling you have and then you go, "But I don't
really know and I'm not going to get into the dis- it's just
like this weird energy vampire thing where I don't know what
the purposes of you sending these like why are you wasting your
time when you don't want your mind changed, you don't want to
have a calm discussion about it. I'm giving you like a a logical
progression of of like premises to follow and you don't engage
with them at all and you just like go, "Well, I don't really
know about that."
Okay, that's fine. Continue.
So it just feels like exhausting to me
decisions that I was making on stream and they were treating
like the stuff that I covered
as like a democratic Like you don't you don't pop up in my chat
overlay anymore, so you're all good. You continue talking with
whoever you like. >> kind of thing and I was a bit confused
>> talk. You're not banned from the chat or anything. Wait
a second, why is You just don't pop up for me, so uh >> are
the things I'm covering on stream
why are people treating this as though this is like a the people
started to view themselves as like having a role in like what
content
I did.
it was a lot.
Like it was a lot and there was like a big old revolt and people
some people left the community and it's fine.
Um but [clears throat] ever since I forget what he's talking
uh Hutch is talking I think about the original Destiny revolt
in his in his chat, right? >> as like a democratic kind
of thing and I was a bit confused at the time cuz I was like,
"Wait a second, why is
like why are the things that I'm covering on stream
uh
like
why are people treating this as though this is like a the people
started to view themselves as like having a role in like what
content
I did.
And uh it was a lot.
Like it was a lot and there was like a big old revolt and people
some people left the community and it's fine.
Um but
ever since then I've just made Well, unfortunately, Evil Johnny
Bravo, we need a different word or we we continue using orbiter
because there seems to be this phenomenon of people who will
not appropriately chastise or describe the person we're talking
about,
In a way that's like so so in their favor, but I man, I I try
not to even think about it cuz other people get like really annoyed
about it. I guess probably like difficult to be a creator and
have this opinion cuz it borders on like, "Oh, I want you to
think what I
So but it does seem like the the coverage or lack of coverage
is very positive in a certain way, but it's >> a concerted
effort to not sort of not cultivate that kind of audience cuz
I'm not looking for that kind of like that level of connection
with like the audience, but
with creators and especially with like big creators and especially
with like big political creators, it creates kind of like a fandom
and an anti-fandom
and these things can be really intense
uh these fandoms and anti-fandoms and like the deep hyperpolarization
between these two groups are kind of like a product of like how
extreme the content creator is. And so Hasan has a intense fandom
and an intense
I don't think it has to do with how extreme their politics are,
to be honest with you. It probably correlates in some way, but
Hasan's community is way less intense than uh
Yeah, I I feel like until Hasan had his breakup with Ethan, Hasan's
community was totally toothless. Hasan's community Hasan had
no motion at all. Hasan needed the breakup with Ethan and Ethan's
anti-fans, Ethan's haters are ruthless, too, okay? And because
they had the breakup, those haters of Ethan became like Hasan
fans and and started defending him. I feel like that's I correct
me if I'm wrong, that's where I think all of Hasan's like motion
in terms of people who will actually, you know, go after the
people who are on him. I think that's where all of his motion
came from was like the H3 haters moving over to Hasan's community.
I don't think Hasan had a a single like
I don't think Hasan had anybody with motion, like nobody who
would go put together clips for him, nobody that would go and
do he had like
I'm trying to think I think even Hasan's actual people who seem
to give him any
actually ex-Destiny fans in the same way as the ex-E- Ethan fans
came in and became his like new sort of like more active and
aggressive community members.
Hold on. Hasan fans are brutal for the normal normie streamers.
You need to look at other victims.
Different victims. Hasan fans are brutal to normie streamers
they can control. Oh, but I don't know do I don't know if those
are are those Hasan fans? Maybe they are Hasan fans. Maybe you
would call them Hassan fans in the same way.
I feel like I feel like lots of those people
lots of those really brutal woke types
I feel like I've gone more of the TikTok crowd and aren't even
like necessarily
But that's just my impression. That's not actually like a good
Oh, sure, sure, sure.
I see what you're saying that that it's like QT and Ludwig and
sure.
But I Again, I think I think there's a separation there, but
I'm not I don't have to push it. It's probably there's probably
a lot of overlap. And realistically, it's like overlap in the
same way where those people probably do like Hassan in some ways
and
People are afraid of Hassan's community. Okay. All right.
I don't see it cuz I've been like at one point on Twitter maybe
the most vocal anti-Hassan A-log and I my life was like easy
street. So, I don't I don't know what to tell you guys. I I I
had no problems whatsoever.
But anti-fandom.
Destiny has an intense fandom and an
anti-fandom. Like I don't want to be in a position where I have
an intense fandom and an intense
And so, I I try to do my best to like I The only conversation
I've ever sought with Hutch was to say, "Hey, I think there's
like this lie going around about me spread maliciously and I'd
like if you could maybe not help that." That's the only conversation.
I never wanted to tell him, "Don't talk about Destiny." I've
never like been like "Oh, you're a Destiny orbiter, you're totally
despicable." I took his side publicly on stream against Qman
on this exact topic and he still wouldn't talk to me. So, I feel
like Like what am I supposed to do when I sit here and I'm like
there's this malicious lie that's being propagated by someone
about me. What was the lie that my community doxed these people
dooby booby. So, that malicious lie is being spread
you literally by because of guilt by association and won't talk
to me. Then I mean, unfortunately, I'm playing like the world's
tiniest violin for you when you tell me that you feel like you're
getting guilty by association.
Not actually. I actually still because I can't help it. I'm like
I'm like the worst kind of up where I still feel like you don't
deserve it. So, I still defend you even though I think you're
doing that exact thing to me and I can't help it. I'll be stuck
here forever trying to like defend Hutch from some tiny mischaracterization
on my stream while he just allows whatever people to say whatever
about me, propagates whatever about me. doesn't give a [__]
Right? Like not have that be a thing.
But I've noticed that with Destiny, it seems like there are a
lot of people who are principally
motivated
by a hatred of Destiny. And in that hate
I mean, I don't like Destiny. I just Unfortunately, after a while
his uh what do you call it? His reputation's at like
Uh it is what it is. >> They go to a place of like often
times delusion. So, if I am covering content
that would have some kind of cross appeal with like I think I've
only said Oh, never mind. I was going to say I think I've only
sent like
one I've sent two DMs. I talked about one I sent
before. One was a request to talk to Hutch and another one was
just basically giving some like some questions or some some points
I thought someone could make to Hutch on a specific topic to
like change his mind on something. Those are like the only two
DMs I've ever sent about Hutch. Like otherwise, I also don't
even I don't like try to go after the guy. Well, sorry, I don't
try to go after the guy for anything personal or anything like
uh private. I do sometimes attack his political opinions cuz
they seem dumb sometimes, okay? Some Oh, and his lack of his
total lack of self-awareness in that he is like a fantastic Hassan
uh A-log, okay? Just admit that your true passion in life is
A-logging Hassan and you like let's just do it, man. You could
totally You could You compete with Nicholas DeOrio, okay? You
could be one of the greatest Hassan A-logs.
I'm just just admit that that is your passion in life, okay?
Stop You can You can leave the closet. There are groups that
can support you through this
Stop living your life in the closet. Come out. Be who you were
meant to be, Hutch. I see Let's crack that egg, okay? Like DGG
then there's this assumption that I am going through my like
the the The accusation seems to be that I'm like I'm waking up
in the morning and I'm going through
like the things that I want to cover that morning
and I'm specifically and surgically like targeting DGG,
which is just so
insane. Who made that assertion? Did he just make that assertion
up?
I I don't know. I I just made something up entirely. I've no
idea who just made that assertion. He just like made up a position
entirely and is hitting himself
Dude, he he just made that up entirely. What is he doing?
There's none of this facts factors into
I'm not sitting here like how how can I get the the most amount
of DGG? Like my
approach with content for years has been
uh like I usually like to be sort of doing my own thing. Um and
it's not that I don't I don't collaborate with people, but I
like kind of being on an island.
Like Umu, you know, games and stuff, like that's one thing, right?
But like especially like politics, like I just, you know,
I don't collaborate like nearly as much as I probably should,
to be honest with you. Esme I think has encouraged me to to do
that more and it's just I prefer I just like not having to rely
on other people in that way. Um
Oh, I While we're while we're doing this, I just realized I have
not shilled in like 2 hours again. Guys, if you like the content,
go ahead uh follow on every platform. All right. Follow on Twitter.
It's x.com/JSTLK_
Follow here on Kick. Obviously, you're doing that already if
you're chatting at all. Okay, join the Discord.
And if you really like the content, you can throw me a couple
bucks. You make the stream go longer. I believe we are six subs
away from another hour on the stream, another 2 hours on the
stream,
So, $6 away, sorry, six subs away, $30
from another 2 hours on the stream. You can sub individually
on Kick. You can give subs on Kick. You can use either of the
donation links. There's Streamlabs and there's Kickbot. All right,
if you want to buy a TTS message.
And yeah, six subs or 30 bucks away from 2 more hours on the
stream. Last but not least, there's Patreon as well.
Hooligans, thank you for the gifted sub. Appreciate it, buddy.
Appreciate you.
There's a couple different membership tiers. We've been doing
lots of additional content here. All right. We've been doing
lots of additional
We're going to keep doing that. I think we're going to do probably
supporter streams most of the time the stream ends early. I might
I think I'm going to start planning uh Euler content as well,
but I probably need to plan that for like the beginning of the
day so people don't miss it and probably plan it in such a way
that I record it but people don't miss it on either side. All
right. So, yeah, multiple tiers in the Patreon. patreon.com/JSTLK.
Go join up. Thank you guys very much for all the support. Thanks,
Hooligans, for the gifted sub and we're back to Hutch.
Uh Pz with the tier one membership.
Jinx with 10 gifted memberships.
Despicable Maul with $10. Hutch, don't take these people seriously.
They're on a personal crusade
to destroy Destiny and if you're not 100% on their side constantly
fighting to achieve it, you're guilty. Yeah.
Uh Sibexin with the tier one membership.
All Elite Memes with $5.
This guy's basically saying you're a Destiny orbiter because
you're both liberals. These overlaps are natural occurrences
with coalitions. Lawson Harrison with $5.
Uh you should just own all of this and take the compliment. Like
K Red with the tier one membership. Hatsukonnomali
with the tier one membership.
Mitchell Blackmore with the tier one membership. Ivan
as well. Space Limes with a gifted sub to Fenton.
Furious Styles with the tier one membership. Lawson with $10.
Destiny adjacent content means you're making based content. Uh
Space Limes with a gifted sub. Despicable Maul with a tier two
membership. Thank you so much for that. And Mac Attack with 43
months. Thank you. I don't want to be dragged
Don't want anything to do Yeah, I saw Sims only message. Yeah.
Who with this kind of
internet Don't think, boy. Now, do you know how fast you were
going?
I have no Now, what is so damn funny? desire. I could have swore
you said
Do I not look like a cat to you, boy?
The donos are absolutely proving Tony Wright. I It's very obvious
he's Like Here's the thing is I think
I think the way I laid it out here is probably
the way you have to do it. But unfortunately, when you lay it
out that way, it just lets them go, "Oh, well, that's like emotional.
That's like you just being overkind or something and so
Uh My Wand X, thank you very much for the five gifted. That's
two more hours on the stream. Let's go. Let's go. Let's
Thank you very much. We're here forever and ever and ever. Long
stream tonight.
Very long stream.
Yeah, it's like um it's more of like an emotional thing. It's
like trying to
Yeah, tap into something else, I guess. So, Tony's video on Hutch
is going to go hard as hell. Maybe.
Yeah, I think um I think the unfortunate thing is is
if I think about like Tony going around
Tony has like totally different goals than I have, right? Tony
probably thinks, if I had to guess, Tony probably thinks these
people are all scum and he's just arguing that they're they're
like scum in a lot of ways, like hypocritical scum.
I don't necessarily see it that way. I think like lots of these
people could be fine. Lots of these people have a hard time perceiving
what's going on. Would Tony call in? Yeah, if I asked Tony to
come on, he'd call in. But um, I think they they just have a
hard time perceiving how other creators would see it. Just whatever.
It is what it is, all right? It is fun to see some of the stuff,
too, though. Uh Royal told me there's a timestamp for some other
[__] going on. Tony's correct.
Um, I mean, I like doing collaboration
And I do think that there's a perception issue, Porter Beller.
Like I do think that these people have a hard time perceiving
what's wrong from other what's going on with other people and
how it's wrong. Right? So,
I understand why it seems like these people are really bad. I
get the fear in a lot of ways. Like Hutch has a family or whatever,
right? He's got like a mortgage and
he's trying to keep his income secure.
So, I sort of I understand a lot of the things going on here
or at least I'm sympathetic to them. Anyway.
All right, I think we Royal told me there's another timestamp
at the end of this. I don't remember what it was, but I'll find
it. Like I'm an adult
person with like
a life
outside of all this.
None of this appeals to me. Maybe it one Oh, hold on. This is
the the just to I probably should have pulled this up a little
sooner.
Okay. But this was the tweet. I was like aware of this tweet
cuz Cherry was responding to him in these tweets or whatever.
Or sorry, Cherry responded
Let's see. Uh after cowering from Queenman and demanding he repeat
Hutchinson's delusion that he isn't a Destiny orbiter, Hutch
is making up doxing allegations against Queenman's community.
Some liar, probably not so erudite, told him privately. Did Hutch
forget it was Ban and Panada who posted his info? I do think
this is the other thing that I'm not good at. I fall into the
same trap. So, it's not even a criticism for Tony, but probably
just if you say
I just don't name people, right? Is it just naming people gives
those people like things to rally against and it sort of works
against you your whole like oh, we shouldn't say these things
unless we know, right?
I do it sometimes, too, and then I try to make it clear like
I actually don't know for sure and don't hold it against people,
but you'd probably just rather they didn't say it at all, right?
Uh does Hutch forget it was Ban and Panada who posted his info?
Okay, I I don't know if you want to watch the clip. I think we've
seen the clip. Queenman also seems to enjoy your content from
what I've gleaned. Uh I think it's gleaned,
just to be clear. All I know is uh Queenman is like dead set
in his mind that um the reason that I won't have a conversation
with him is that I'm like afraid of his debate skills.
That's not it at all. I think he uses it in the same way that
Pisco would use it as like you're you're trying to evade a conversation,
right? So, he's going to say it and call you a chicken. But I
think he understands like what you're what you're doing when
you do avoid. I think he understands
I think it's also that there's like a couple different things
going on there, okay? It's like very I I don't think that Queenman's
under the impression that you know enough about his debate skills
that you're dodging him on that alone. >> very convinced.
Sometimes clips land on my feed. And it was it and it was literally
just that I just like people started spreading Yeah, Queenman's
community does a lot of harm to his reputation, to be honest.
Wow. There's what it is. >> my doxx
like shortly before I was set to have a conversation with this
person.
And this was after somebody else privately reached out to me
and said, "Watch out for that." Like not as much harm as obviously
like the malicious lies from Willy Mac or Destiny does. So, at
some point I like I don't have a lot of criticism, but I do think
in terms of if you think you could talk to somebody, if you have
a bunch of people in your comments constantly calling you like
a
you're totally right now, just constantly I do see why somebody
who who purports to who claims to only want to do politics despite
doing, you know, a thousand hours of Colorgate,
somebody who claims that they're they might not engage. cuz they're
kind of crazy and they doxx people and it's like very toxic.
And I was like, "I'll be fine." And then before I even had the
conversation,
that happened. I was like, Oh, now I really want to know who
said that. Now I really really really want to know who said that.
Oh, that's a very interesting thing, isn't it? Don't don't talk
to this guy, he doxxes. Oh, I'll be fine. Doxx posted immediately.
Interesting. Okay. Well, maybe people were right about that community.
And so then I just
decided I'm not going to go in that community. Have conver- Queenman
the doxxer, why do you run cover for the at J stock? Cuz I think
Queenman actually puts a lot more work into his political opinions
than 99.9%
of people who talk about politics and it feels really weird to
me and shitty that somebody who does have like interesting opinions,
will argue them, will argue them like uh will argue them, how
do I put it? Like aggressively, won't back down, will actually
say what he thinks, that he can't have conversations because
he's been lied about. That feels really it just feels super shitty
to me.
Uh it feels like if somebody was doing that about me, I'd be
I would hope that my friends would have my back on that.
So, it feels like I can't really not have his back on that. conversations
with those people. All right, anyway. So, there's the end of
the Hutch clip. Totally wrong, that's like saying gropers are
bad for Nick's career when they're like half the reason for Nick's
success. Um
Yes. Yes. Uh I would say long long long term, ultra long term,
the super aggressive super cult like gropers are good for you
and building that up. Now, it'll depend on how much that hurts
you in the medium term, right? And how much you've got to be
correct on things and have things swing in your direction and
that's pretty difficult for a lot of people to do. Nick Nick
Fuentes himself infamously had a horrible time of this, right?
Nick Fuentes himself literally was constantly depressed, constantly
couldn't get up to do his show because he'd see how like his
community and the way they'd acted had caused like everybody
to move away from him and he had like he was losing viewers,
he was he was slowly fading, he was deplatformed from everything,
right? Like I totally get it it it's a tough line to walk. It
can work out tremendously and having that cult like following,
like the extremely devoted following who are hyper aggressive,
can be extremely good. But certainly I think if Nick had just
himself three years ago, it's pretty difficult to argue. Like
it took him years and years and years of being
cast aside by everybody for him to pull it back.
that's like some
that's a kind of strategy that is very hit or miss, I think.
Former community member who Queenman made. Do you think Food
Chops was a member of Queenman's community?
Is that what you think?
I think Food Chops just got like mocked mercilessly by Queenman
until they quit making content the first time. Oh, you're memeing.
I got you. I got you. I got you. Okay.
Okay. Okay. Yeah. The other side of this is I feel like um a
lot of people if they watch this, I think they go like, "Wait,
you guys aren't nice to Erudite. Why uh like why should they
be nice to you or something? Why should like Erudite's friends
be nice to you?" I feel like that would be a comment we get back.
Again, I think probably anything I've ever said about Erudite
I'd be willing to talk to her on stream about.
I'm not like worried about that at all.
I I say things and I'll say things like in a joking way or I'll
say like mean things, but in terms of criticizing her opinions
or saying like what she's done, I explicitly, I think,
I've explicitly held back from saying that stuff in public or
even in private to people, like stuff that I would have thought
about her in the past.
Yeah, so I don't know. I I think I have a lot more discipline
there. I think I am totally fine to put down my record against
anyone
To be honest with you.
Oh, I was going to want to read some of the replies here. Hold
on. Wait, so you had the perfect opportunity to grill me on this
in the Discord today and instead of you instead you stammered
through, and I'm not even joking in the slightest but the next
part, one of the most idiotic arguments I've ever seen a part
ever been a part of in all my years of
I was building up to it. I wanted to establish that you were
overreaching on Platner and then go into this.
You could not follow an extremely basic train of thought. It
happened like three times in a row. That's not true. I understood
what you were saying and I was laying out my reasoning, but you
kept making baseless accusations and booted me. Bro.
I feel blackpilled.
Wait, is this uh maybe we'll watch this. Give me a second. Yeah,
I was there. I remember. Damn, he made a screenshot collage of
my [__] and about it in his alerts channel in the
middle of the night, but you he's cutting his own clips about
you from his stream. Well done, sir. Yeah, Hutch does let his
his like some of his viewers and critics live in his head. Dude,
it's crazy that Hutch will cut away from actual content to follow
new Ogre Boy tweets. That's like he's so obsessed with Hasan
that he has become obsessed with the most the second most obsessed
person with Hasan. He sees Ogre Boy as his primary competition
in Hasan obsession and he's decided to take him the [__]
out, okay? He's going to kill Ogre Boy's career in its crib.
that's crazy, all right?
That's some insane stuff. All right. Um what else we got going
on? I think I was going to read Cherry's comment here. What was
it? I agree Kweiman didn't dox or encourage doxing Hutch, but
Hutch didn't make up any allegations. He clearly says the concern
was privately stressed to him by someone else and reinforced.
Kweiman being petty about the label orbiter in response is understandable,
but that doesn't make him right. It's quite boring to stun lock
this to stun lock this misunderstanding when the debates on politics
would be such better content.
He said it was privately stressed to him. We don't know if they
showed evidence and reinforced by BadBunny publishing his info
when BadBunny BadBunny is not connected to Kweiman. The part
he made up is that BadBunny doxing him is somehow connected to
Kweiman. He shouldn't be repeating baseless allegations.
Is he not just being consistent in relaying the same order of
events to chatters who insist on asking him the same question?
What are you expecting to change if they're both egotistically
stun locked? If the same story if the story changed or he started
giving less
story changed or he started giving less info, I would say that
sucks.
But he doesn't do that. He's very up front about what happened,
why he believes it happened. So much so that the info you'd need
to defend Kweiman being maligned as as the cause without proof
is included even in this clip.
To defend Okay. If you don't want him to repeat his perspective,
people should stop asking. If tomorrow he was he has perfect
information and can know Kweiman did nothing to dox him in poking
for a in poking him for a debate, he would still repeat this
exact understanding of why he canceled that debate and remain
distant from that space. Be thankful some people are willing
to be very up front about their ignorance. Okay, wait. So I'm
guessing if you watch
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Uh Kweiman
Kweiman also seems Let me Let me listen to this again and see
what I think. >> your content from what I've gleaned. Uh
I think it's gleaned, just to be clear. All I know is Kweiman
is like dead set in his mind that um the reason that I won't
have a conversation with him is that I'm like afraid of his debate
skills. He's like very convinced. Sometimes clips land on my
feed. And it was it and it was literally
just that I just like people started spreading my doxx like shortly
before I was set to have a conversation with this
And this was after somebody else privately reached out to me
and said, "Watch out for that community because they're kind
of crazy and they dox people and it's like very toxic." And I
was like, "I'll be fine." And then before I even had the conversation
Okay. >> that happened. I was like, "Okay, well, maybe
people were right about that community." And so then I just
decided I'm not going to go in that >> Wait, am I Am I
crazy? And this was after somebody else privately doxx And it
was literally
just that I just Sorry, I'm looking My My trackpad just went
out like in the middle of me about to zoom in something. And
so I'm looking for a lightning cable for my trackpad as well.
Give me a second. >> People started spreading my doxx like
shortly before I was set to have a conversation with this person.
And this was after somebody else privately reached out to me
and said, "Watch out for that Where's the BadBunny >> community
because they're kind of crazy and they dox people and it's like
very toxic." And I was like, "I'll be fine." And then before
I even had the
that happened. I was like, "Okay, well, maybe people were right
about that community." And so then I just
decided I'm not going to go in that community. I don't Where
did they get into the Does Hutch forget it was BadBunny who posted
his info? It wasn't He's talking about the the doxing that happened
on somewhere else. He's He's I I think Tony might maybe have
Trackpad is an accessory. Wait, no, the trackpad is for this
Give me a second. I need to put something on for you guys cuz
I need to walk away and get my get a lightning cable. I'll be
right back. One point in my career
this would have appealed to me. Maybe I would have wanted to
like get in there.
>> But I'm just so well past that at this point and it's
just not it doesn't hit like it used to. Um but anyways,
the fandoms and the anti-fandoms can be like equally strong.
And because Destiny
um through the choices that he makes
there was a tweet from him yesterday that was like very
uh intense.
And uh so so he is intentionally provocative and that's just
what he wants to do.
And that's one of the reasons why I actually don't want a relationship
with him. Cuz I don't want to be a part of any of that. Like
I don't want to be even
secondhand accountable for any of that.
That's the choice that he
makes in terms
how he wants to behave on the internet. And yet I can't seem
to escape it
Okay, hang on. Naughty pup, you there?
Well, I had questions for I I actually wanted him in the in the
voice. I just don't want like
any of this. I am not interested
in any any of this. >> I just I need a I don't know if
he's still listening or not, but we literally I made a command.
I have been since I've started being a mod. I have a sentence.
I fine-tuned it so it fits in there that you don't want to debate
him, you don't want to confront him, you have nothing to do with
him, you will um react to his content and with your own things.
Your >> back though. >> Your chat lit We have a command
Guys, we have a command. Exclamation point Destiny. Exclamation
point Destiny. Also, why the is Hutch not letting Tony talk to
this >> literally is not parasocial. We will argue with
you over colors and games and food and movies. We're not a cult.
And for someone to sit there and say that you're some kind of
order orbiter or you're trying to gain
people to watch you by commenting on his stuff. It's not true.
And it's
And if he goes and makes a video or goes and spews his [__]
on Twitter and like everybody likes to do on Twitter Well, no,
I mean it's not going to be correct. It's going to be false.
>> Well, they're going to They're going to do that. That's
fine. Like it shows up in my mentions.
And that's fine. Like I can't you can't like stop that from happening.
It just it is what it is. So. I know that, but everything he
said Well, most of everything that he said is bad faith and it's
Just wanted to say that. >> that, Naughty pup. Yeah. And
I want YouTube to like the stream. Yeah, there you go. >> It's
All right, thanks. It's bad faith and it's
I mean
I don't think it's bad faith. I think There's just like a total
lack You say the word Destiny and Hutch is like, "I'm going to
purposely misunderstand
Which sucks.
I think Tony was
honestly like respectable, calm, and
I've seen Hutch do this. I don't know how how do people like
this as a tactic? Now, this is a comment purely on Hutch's streaming
style, but how is it like a tactic to pretend to be [__]
and then people want to watch?
Like you make no effort whatsoever to understand. Like it's And
it's like incredibly obvious at least to me what Tony's trying
to argue. It's It's not mean. It's not like rude. I actually
disagree with him, but I think he explains himself quite well.
And then like your reaction is to pretend to be a [__]
that can't understand him.
How is that entertaining? Like I just don't get where the entertainment
is that you're like pretending to be too stupid to understand.
Or you Or I mean not pretending. One of the two. I just I don't
get it. Anyway. Yeah, I Like I I just disagree with what Tony's
saying. I don't think Tony did a bad job of like explaining himself.
He did a good job of explaining himself.
Anyway, I think this is the This is the mod timestamp, right,
Ralph?
We ended up waiting into this. Um they reverse engineered the
logic and then there's no like you can't you can't like pull
back.
And like I've noticed
Oh, you know, you're not wrong, King of
You're not wrong that the Oreo does
Like very often actually. In fact, it's what he did when he first
watched me talk to Willy back, right?
It's It's literally like a tactic, like
Wait, oh yeah, sure, sure, sure. Whatever you say, man. Okay.
Yeah, okay, okay. Okay, I guess.
Sure, dude. Sure, dude. Sure, dude. Yeah, I I can I can think
of how Nicholas does it. Kind of annoying. All right. I think
we're pretty much done with the Hutch stuff, right? >> When
I try to have conversations I even had a conversation with somebody
like privately off stream.
Uh I won't even say who, you know, cuz
it was supposed to be a private conversation. Uh this person
just kept on showing up in my mentions.
And uh they kept on like making the same
uh and they were like, "You know, we can just have a conversation,
you know, in a Discord off stream."
And I think that they were uh
I think that they were not expecting me to say yeah. And I was
like, "You know what? Fine. Let's do it."
What Why? I This is another thing Hutch does. Maybe everyone
does it. I probably do it, right? Sometimes when you [clears throat]
have like combative content, you used to like you know, every
every It's like the every problem becomes a nail thing. You know,
when when a hammer's your only tool, every problem becomes a
nail. It's like you're going to be combative with everybody.
It's like I bet this person didn't even think they were going
to talk to me. It's like why did they Why would they have asked
you? Why do you think they would have asked you to talk if they
didn't think you were going to talk to them?
I really shocked them when I said, "Yeah, I'll talk." Like, "Okay,
what do you Why do you think they asked you to talk? Because
they didn't want to? They just wanted to prove a point? Which
is leaving to take a [__] while your opponent lays
out their argument? Can't possibly Or sorry.
Uh Kaya just dismoved. Strategy is powerful, I can't lie. Dude,
the I can't believe he said it. Like who does that? That was
crazy to me. Like, "Hey, I need a I need to be right back. Yeah,
I'm going to be right back. My bad. I I need to go do something."
Right? Who lays it out that they're like, "Hey, I'm going to
go take a [__] fat shit." Like say whatever you want
to say, I'll be right back. I'm going to take a fat [__]
right now.
And so I had a conversation with this person for like 30 minutes,
maybe like 20 minutes, 20 to 30 minutes.
And then um like I thought it was like a semi-reasonable
conversation, like I thought it was. And then uh like literally
5 minutes later
they tagged me in a tweet
like talking about some of the stuff that we said in private.
And this this person was the one that asked me if I wanted to
have a private
And I was like and it there was nothing
Like I'm not I don't care.
It was not food shops.
It was not food shops. No. But it was like, "Okay."
Like there comes a point when you're having conversations with
these people and like part of me is I got to be honest with you
guys. Like part of me is kind of like fascinated cuz it's kind
of like an interesting experience being on the side >> on.
Did that didn't finish tonight, did it? Oh, it did cuz somebody
said Canada suffered a huge L. Oh, that's too bad. I don't I
literally don't care about baseball, so that's tough. Like I
I wanted the Jays to win. I had heard it went to seven games.
But um Oh, that's too bad, man.
It's too bad.
Uh I would have wanted the Jays to win, but I like straight up
I like I actually despise baseball. Like it's just the sh- sport
I can't imagine ever watching it again. So
I like I This is the one thing where I I feel nothing about it.
Like I would feel something about Canada's soccer team losing
way more than baseball. It was an amazing World Series. Yeah,
oh actually H- brain or H- H- brain, the only thing I actually
do like about baseball is the guy on the Dodgers, the Asian guy
who can pitch and hit home run homers, Ohtani, yeah, the Ohtani
guy. That's like That's the cool thing about baseball. Like an
like an the [__] best maybe the best belt best baseball
player ever existing, that's cool. I like that. But other than
other than that, it's whatever, boring.
Like accusations like this. Like when I wake up in the morning,
I pick up my phone and I just like I pull up in Twitter and this
is what I do for like
This is what I do for like an hour.
I just go like this and then I bookmark
And then I'll go I'll open up like the YouTube app.
And I'll just keep refreshing and see if you know And I I try
to subscribe to people that I think would make interesting content.
And then I kind of pull together a list of things
I think are personally
um
Okay, he's talking about how he does his dog [__]
Okay, like what do I think that like my viewers will think is
interesting. But at no point
in any of this process, at any point am I thinking about like
how do I target DGG? Yeah, I don't know this is a total hallucination
that he thinks anyone that anyone thinks he does this is just
a complete hallucination.
Literally not a single person thinks this happens.
I can go look. Trust me, I know some of the most unhinged anti-Destiny
people in the world. I know them.
I guarantee you they don't think this. I know some of the most
unhinged anti-Hutch people in the world.
In fact
Porter Bellows here all the time and I don't think he thinks
this. He doesn't think you sit there thinking about how you could
possibly just most maximally curate your stream to DGG. He doesn't
think you do that. Nobody thinks you do
It has nothing to do with anything.
I don't think about Destiny
very much. The the the honestly like 95% of the time that Destiny
pops into my head it's because someone's in my
or in my Discord
accusing me of this stuff.
These people think about that Destiny
100,000 times more than I Wait, did Ohtani like play really good
tonight, too? Oh, just before the series, I see. Do I see it
every day?
I just don't want any of that noise.
That's like literally the reason why. That's like basically the
reason why
I decided to you know put space between me and Destiny.
So Porter Bellows says he doesn't think that Hutch does that,
but he's going to start saying it now.
Listen, I disavow this guy Hutch in the strongest possible terms.
I disavow this guy, okay? >> Because it's just
>> When you're a part of that like circle of friends
it's very noisy.
And like so much of your online identity
becomes about like Destiny, which is I'm that's not me criticizing
people that are you know in his orbit or whatever. That's not
me making like a judgment call of them.
but it's just something that I don't really want. Like I don't
really want that. Um that's too noisy for me. I spent 9 hours
reacting to a Destiny video. I spent the 9 hours it was more
like me Uh Sims Ahoy, I think this is just mostly like not making
jokes about Destiny and like the allegations. I think it's Like
right? He would never lean away from another creator's stuff
if he didn't have like some kind of personal relationship. I
think that's what people see it as. Right? Or sorry, I think
that's like what people see is like some soft defense and
I don't know. I have a hard time getting mad about that now.
I used to definitely. I think I went too hard on like right when
the allegations dropped. I think I went a little too hard on
Pisco specifically about like the way he handled it. Uh not even
like crazy. I think I was just like I didn't like the way he
talked about it or something. I think that was just like too
much. I don't think he liked being um Oh, no, he had a tweet
that I didn't like. He had a tweet that was like stupid. He had
a tweet that was like, "I get that Destiny did things wrong,
but at least he's not Trump" or something about but at least
he didn't vote for Trump. And I was like, "Bro, are you kidding
me?" To be honest, that was a pretty stupid tweet. Just the way
he I don't think he meant what he said, but it was pretty [__]
stupid tweet,
I I probably could have not blown him up in public over it, though.
Maybe, I don't know. [__] arguing with chat.
Um that was like the bulk of all that. It would be impossible
to not talk about Destiny because he's such a loud voice and
in the same world.
I mean, he's going to come up and if there's something that he
says that provokes a larger conversation
and something that he's said uh becomes
or or touches on something that was topical for me
>> What are we doing here? uh sometimes I'll react to his
content, but that's pretty limited.
It's not a very um
common occur- So I've got for the rest of the night I've got
Ice Poseidon talked to Eddie on his thing. I might check out
some of that. I do think I want to do the JD Vance Groper stuff,
but that's like an early stream thing. I don't know if I'm going
to do it now.
and then I don't really have much else,
I don't know, we'll see. I might need some new stuff to go over.
We'll check it out. I'll see what what's in the Discord. I haven't
really looked at Discord much in the past day and a half, we'll
see what's going on for links in there. Anyways.
I get it in my head sometimes that like maybe I can have a conversation
with someone and maybe this person can be like the reasonable
person.
Maybe this person can be like the exception to the rule.
Like maybe I can have a conversation and they can just behave
like a normal adult and then you have stuff like um
this person Tony where
like there comes a point in the conversation where you realize
like he's he's he's reached the conclusion and he's reverse engineering.
And there's like no way that you can
And so then it just becomes like a I'd like I think of this more
seriously if Hutch like had made any effort at all to try to
speak. He'd made any effort at all, but he made no effort. There's
just no effort. Waste of time.
What's wrong with Tony? He sounds obsessed. That's what's going
on. He sounds obsessed.
It looks [laughter] like With what? Destiny anti-fandom.
He sounds obsessed with like
anti-fandom. This guy
>> wonder like what words did he use that made it seem
like he was obsessed. I guess he tweets.
Yeah, I guess I guess he's I guess he tweets.
I don't know. I think I don't know why having like a specific
thing you follow makes you bad or not worth talking to.
Like if if Tony came in was like totally crazy in the chat or
sorry, in the call, I would understand.
But Tony didn't really seem crazy at
Bro, 20 audience members. I thought the 20 people in the disagreements,
that's pretty tangible to me, but maybe Hutch maybe Hutch's audience
is way bigger than I thought and he gets 20 people in his waiting
room for most topics.
Like when he's like, "Hey, I want to discuss UBI." Maybe he gets
like 20, 30 people in his waiting room to talk to talk UBI with
them.
Tunes into my stream for hours and hours and hours, multiple
days in a row.
Compiling evidence and
putting a video together. Hutch realizes he does that with Hasan,
right?
Do you think you're totally unhinged and unreliable on Hasan
and nobody should ever talk to you? Like is this Is this the
bar we want to set here? Oh, this guy spends a ton of time following
one creator, following like them extremely specifically, so he
can put together he can compile evidence and make a case.
It's like, "Okay. Uh so, nobody else can talk to somebody who
does that?" Uh-oh.
That's not great.
Nope, it's only when you have a I disagree with Destiny Day when
these viewers want to correct him. Well, I know that Ogre Boy.
I know that that's how it is. I know that that's how it is.
That's the
I don't know. How should How should I explain this to people?
There's like a thing. There's like something I should be able
to explain.
Um like sometimes there are things that aren't worth fighting
on, that you let go, that you don't bring up, so that you can
have like a more tangible conversation. I think with Hutch, like
bringing up his obsession with Hasan and then calling him like
an orbiter, these are like two things that if you avoid these
things, he mostly doesn't have his brain shut down. Right? It
remains running at whole 100%
But if you mention these things, he sort of like instantly it
just bogs it down entirely, like starts static starts forming
in his brain and he can't listen or talk.
And so, I would probably try to
I would probably try to stay away from those things, to be honest
with you. Yeah, I would just probably try to stay away from those
things.
But again, um I think It sounds like I'm criticizing Tony. He
did pretty well. It's way easier to think of these things from
a third-party perspective, watching the content after the fact.
It's like so so so much harder to when you're speaking to somebody
in the moment to maintain like total distance from the conversation
and look at it and make these points. Learning deep lore for
hours and hours and hours.
Um like I can't believe
Let me just show you.
Like this is what's going on.
>> Let me pull this off the screen.
Like this is just one example of a like what I'm talking about
here. Wait, this Ogre Boy tweet is awesome.
Bro, Ogre Boy is like just honest. He's just earnest. I don't
know why do I I don't understand how Hutch like hates Ogre Boy,
to be honest with you. I actually don't get it. They're like
perfect foils for each other, too.
I don't know.
I don't I don't see how
I don't see how Hutch like
What is wrong with this I have to hear what's wrong with this
guy.
Is it? There's a lot going on here. Like yeah, Hutch, I'm not
doing this for
Like Ogre Boy, you're here right now.
I feel like there's just no way Hutch hasn't blocked you. I feel
like there's just no way that he could actually dislike you.
Like it feels like this almost has to be kayfabe. Because if
he disliked you and you take up like this much of his thought
space and time, why wouldn't he just I don't understand why he
doesn't block you. I just assume he would block, cuz I like you
take up so much of his mental space all the time.
There has to be some Sundering going on, some Sundery thing where
he is like he he just has to tell everybody he hates you all
the time. He's unblocked me twice. Okay. I
Yeah, it's It do be like that. That may be what drives people
like you with your clips and your viral moments, scrolling through
Ox's feed
hoping maybe he got you this time.
Me, it's just something I do in between menial tasks at the old
widget factory.
I put you on in the background.
uh or maybe a little music, too. And occasionally blow out a
co-worker's
when I tell them when I say, "What the [__] did blah
blah blah." Anyways, I'll take this post uh every day of the
week over every coward on the internet who watches this stuff
obsessively and then pretends they don't give a [__]
They're like, "I don't even care about this right now." Could
you imagine? Like Ogre Boy doesn't do that. Ogre Boy never goes,
"I don't give a fuck."
That's the worst kind of human, the nihilistic type type of person
who's just like they're they're arguing something and then they're
like losing. They're like, "I don't even care about this. I don't
even care about this. So gay." Ah, I like I like become enraged.
There's like a vein that's going to appear on my forehead just
thinking about it. People who do that [__] okay?
Just believe what you believe. It's like
That's a pretty remarkable problem?
It's like the exact reason. By the way, I like Quiman for the
exact reason I like Ogre Boy, for that same trait. Where it's
like they'll believe something and they'll just actually believe
it. And they're not going to like fall back from believing it.
They're never going to go, "Oh, I don't really care."
That doesn't happen.
It's like the They're not boring like >> a thing to write
on the internet about yourself. You think about me when you're
You think about me late at night, you know, like I got a
reply from him like 11:00 p.m.
You think about me when you're at work. That's when you stream,
bro. I think he says he puts your stream on to listen in the
background.
Probably when you're live streaming.
So, he probably was like sitting there doing his job, listening
to your live
So, if that probably when you're watching somebody's live stream
or listening to it, that's probably when you go, "Hey, I'm thinking
about this live stream."
just I'm throwing out like a crazy
crazy idea here. I know that that's out of this world. I know
it's almost it's entirely unbelievable.
seems like that. Yeah, I don't know. Uh 1 second.
Hey, could I get that lady? All right, good to go. That's a lot.
Like that's a lot. There's a
Is Hutch just at all of his viewers right now? I mean, I assume
so, yeah. I'm guessing a ton of his viewers are listening while
watching at work. Oh, let's see here. Is he all right? Crazy
dude. Oh, he sounds like a great
I mean, it sounds like he just cares. I don't know.
I don't It would be one thing like if
I'm I'm not like knocking him or whatever. That's not you know.
It would be one thing if like he was
getting paid for it, you know, like
Uh sounds like he is getting paid for it, kind of. No? Making
money from it, you know.
flop tuber who actually like
made money from it, okay? Wait, I don't know how much Ogre Boy
even engages in the drama I feel like Ogre Boy doesn't engage
in the drama stuff. He engages way more in the politics stuff.
That at least I can somewhat, you know,
understand, but he's just I don't know why he watches Hutch streams.
Bro, how How deranged would it be if there was a company that
monetized you commenting on Hutch streams? Wouldn't that be deranged
I that would be weird.
That'd be really weird. What kind of weirdo would get that kind
of job? But that that kind of obsession is just like I don't
really
I don't really want to, you know,